COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME BACK
DUE TO THE ONGOING COVERT
NINETEEN RESTRICTIONS WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL SO WE'RE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WALK AND
PARTICIPATE. IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. NASSAR REQUIRED FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEARING ROOM
IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY FIVE OF THE CAPITAL. AT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS. YOU CAN
TESTIFY IN PERSON IN THE
HEARING ROOM AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION OR BY USING
OUR TELEPHONE SERVICE. THE
NUMBER TO CALL IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. THAT NUMBER IS ALSO ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. FOR
EACH BILL BEING DISCUSSED TODAY
THERE WILL BE OPPORTUNITY FOR
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. TO PROVIDE TWO
MINUTES EACH OF COMMENTARY. FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES CALLING
INTO THE PHONE LINE. OR IN THE
ROOM YOU'LL BE PLACING QUEUE
UNTIL YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. IF
YOU'RE ALLING BY PHONE YOU
MUST MUTE YOUR DEVICE TO REDUCE
SOUND DISTORTIONS. SUPPORTED
OPPOSITION WILL BE BLENDED ON
THE PHONE LINES PLEASE BE BRIEF
AND LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS ONLY TO
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IN YOUR
POSITION. AND NOT TO TESTIMONY.
IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE DIRECTLY AT. NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE THREE. AND MY STAFF WILL
TRY TO HELP YOU. I ENCOURAGE
THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WHERE WE
CAN SEE MORE OF YOUR THOUGHTS.
FINALLY THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMEDIAN FOR
PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE REMOVING A
MASKING REFUSING TO PUT IT BACK
ON. TALKING OR MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE SPEAKING
LONGER THAN THE TIME ALLOTTED.
EXTENDED DISCUSSION OF MATTERS
NOT RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF
THE HEARING OR THE BILL AND
OTHER DESTRUCTIVE ACTS. TO
ADDRESS ANY DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT
I WILL TAKE THE FOLLOWING
STEPS. IF AN INDIVIDUAL
DISRUPTS OUR HEARING PROCESS I
WILL DIRECT THEM TO STOP AND
WARN THEM NOT CONTINUE
DISRUPTIONS MAY RESULT IN
REMOVAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE WILL ALSO DOCUMENT
ON THE RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED IN THE NATURE OF
DESTRUCTIVE COMMENT. OR CONDUCT
I MAY TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF THE CONDUCT DOES
NOT STOP I WILL REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS AND
EXPLORING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
CORPORATION WE HAVE A LOT OF
IMPORTANT WORK TO GET DONE. AND
IT'S TO THE BENEFIT OF ALL
CALIFORNIA IF WE CAN PROCEED
WITHOUT INTERRUPTION. WITH THAT
WE WILL BEGIN OUR HEARING. A
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FRIEDMAN HERE. FONG
BERMAN. CUNNINGHAM DALY. DAVIES
GIPSON. KALRA WE- MEDINA. THIS
AREA. WHEN DONALD. WARD WICKS.
REFORM WITH CUNNINGHAM WILL
FORM OKAY WE HAVE THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES ON CONSENT ACR FIFTY
ONE ACR NINETEEN ACR TWENTY
SEVEN AB TEN SEVENTY SIX AB
SEVEN NINETY EIGHT ACR SIXTY
FOUR- TODAY. FIRST UP WE HAVE A
MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- TODAY I
BEFORE WE TAKE THE ROLL CALL I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT TODAY WE
HAVE ONE MEMORIAL HIGHWAY NAMED
FOR A WOMAN AND ANOTHER FOR A
MAN THIS IS THE FOURTH HIGHWAY
NAMING FOR MAN MEANING THAT WE
ARE NEARING MY LIMIT OF FIVE
HIGHWAYS NAME FOR MEN UNTIL THE
WOMEN CATCH UP. LET'S CONTINUE
TO WORK TO PASS AN EQUAL NUMBER
OF HIGHWAYS NAMED AFTER WOMEN
SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I AM
NOT CONSENT FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN IPHONE FONG HI BERMAN.
BERMAN HI CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM CONSENT ITEMS ON.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON- OUR
GIPSON AYE KALRA. KALRA HIGHLY
LI HI MEDINA. MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
WHEN O'DONNELL. WARD WICKS
WICKS I. THE CURRENT VOTE IS.
ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN TO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS PASSED AND
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND I WILL ASK
MEMBERS THAT IF YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO VOTE ON A MEASURE TO
SAY YOU'RE NOT VOTING BECAUSE
IT'S HARD FOR THE SECRETARY TO
HEAR WHAT DO YOU VOTED OR NOT.
THANK YOU- WE HAVE THREE BILLS
TO DISCUSS TODAY. AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN MCCARTY. AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE REYES AND AB FORTY
THREE BY NY. I DO NOT SEE
MISTER MCCARTY. IF HE DOESN'T.
OR IS THIS THE I DON'T SEE HIM
SO UNTIL HE APPEARS I WILL
ALLOW FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES
TO PRESENT HER BILL. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MA'AM MADAM THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO REPRESENT TO YOU
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE WHICH
WILL MODERNIZE THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. BY
REVISING ITS PROJECT
PREFERENCES TO SUPPORT
INVESTMENTS IN OUR MOST
POLLUTED AREAS. THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM HAS BEEN
A CRUCIAL TOOL TO ADVANCE CLEAN
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PROGRAM
RECEIVES APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
TO DEPLOY INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT TRANSFORM
CALIFORNIA'S FUEL AND VEHICLE
TYPES. THESE ARE SPECIAL FUNDS
THAT HAVE BEEN EARMARKED FOR
THIS PROGRAM. AND CAN ONLY BE
SPENT ON TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS THE PROGRAM WAS LAST
UPDATED IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AND SINCE THEN. THERE
HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF CLIMATE
POLICIES AND DEVELOPMENTS IN
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY THAT WARRANT A
DISCUSSION ON THE PRIORITIES OF
THIS PROGRAM. AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE WILL INCORPORATE
PROGRAM CHANGES THAT WILL FOCUS
INVESTMENTS. IN THE EMERGING
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY FREIGHT
INDUSTRY. ADVOCATE FUNDING TO
PROJECTS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDE
PREFERENCES FOR PROJECTS TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS. AND
PARTICULATE MATTER IN OUR MOST
POLLUTED AREAS. CALIFORNIA HAS
SOME OF THE WORST AIR QUALITY
IN THE COUNTRY TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS MAKE UP 50% OF ALL
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA AND ARE
THE MAIN CONTRIBUTOR TO POOR
AIR QUALITY. THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THE INLAND EMPIRE IN THE
GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA ARE
CURRENTLY CLASSIFIED AS
EXTREME. NON ATTAINMENT AREAS
UNDER THE FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT.
MANY OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
SUCH AS THE BAY AT BAY AREA
SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO RANGE FROM
MODERATE TO SEVERE NON
ATTAINMENT. CALIFORNIA HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A LEADER IN
ADDRESSING OUR QUALITY BUT IT'S
CLEAR THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE. CLEANING UP THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS
CRITICAL TO DEMONSTRATING THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT NOT ONLY
CAN CO EXIST BUT ARE
COMPLEMENTARY TO EACH OTHER.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TODAY IS MEREDITH
ALEXANDER WITH CAL STAR. AND
BUILD MCGOVERN WITH THE HELP
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR. THANK
YOU WE HAVE A MOTION THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION THE SECOND LET'S-
BRING THE WITNESSES IN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR FRIEDMAN I
MEMBERS. THANK YOU CAN HEAR ME
YEAH I'M MAD ABOUT. POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CAL START HERE IS
THE SPONSOR OF EIGHTY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. FIRST WE WISH TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIGHT YES
FOR HER WONDERFUL LEADERSHIP ON
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION ISSUES AND
FOR OFFERING THIS MEASURE. CAL
START IS AN INTERNATIONAL
MEMBER BASED NONPROFIT WITH
OVER TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
MEMBERS DEDICATED TO
TRANSFORMING THE TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY. COMPRISED OF PEOPLE
MANUFACTURERS ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY AN ALTERNATE FUEL
PRODUCERS PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
FLEETS AND MORE. THE ENERGY
COMMISSION'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM HAS BEEN
A CRITICAL ELEMENT OF OUR
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION AND
CLIMATE PROGRAMS. HOWEVER THE
STATE HAS PASSED MANY LANDMARK
CLIMATE LAWS SINCE THIS PROGRAM
WAS FIRST ESTABLISHED OVER
THIRTEEN YEARS AGO. AND SINCE
THEN WE'VE ADOPTED AMBITIOUS
MANDATES FOR CLEAN VEHICLES AND
SET MANY SPECIFIC VEHICLE
EMISSIONS REDUCTION TARGETS SO
IT MAKES SENSE TO MODIFY THE
STATUTE THAT GUY THESE
PROGRAMS. TO ENSURE THAT IT
REFLECTS OUR CURRENT GOALS AS
WELL AS RECENT TECHNOLOGICAL
TECHNOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENTS
MARKET TRENDS. SO THAT WE CAN
INCREASE THE PACE OF PROGRESS.
AND ALSO CRITICALLY ENSURE
CLEAN AIR FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AS WELL AS EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. SO THIS
PROGRAM IS REALLY MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER FOR EXAMPLE%
THE STATE NEEDS TO REACH ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION LIGHT DUTY
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGERS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. AND WE NEED TO
RAPIDLY SCALE UP INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
EASIER EMISSION VEHICLES WHICH
WILL BEGIN RAPIDLY COMING TO
MARKET BECAUSE OF THE ADVANCING
TRUCK ROLL. ANOTHER CARD
REGULATION. IT PRETTY THREE
THAT WE HAPPY SPONSOR THIS BILL
AND WORK WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I'M IN PARTICULAR WE KNOW EXTRA
SUPPORT IS NEEDED FOR SMALL
FLEETS WHO WILL HAVE A HARDER
TIME ACCORDING TO YOUR EMISSION
VEHICLES AND INFRASTRUCTURE. WE
APPRECIATE HER FOCUS ON NOT.
AND WELCOME CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
AS THE BILL GOES THROUGH THE
PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS FILLED THE GAP FOR AND
WITH THE COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR. MOST OF OUR WORK AT THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IS
DEVOTED TO CLEANING UP THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR BECAUSE-
IN CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
ACCOUNTS FOR. 80% OF OUR LOCAL
AIR POLLUTION AND ABOUT 50% OF
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
WHEN YOU INCLUDE THE UPSTREAM
EMISSIONS. WE ARE ALSO ONE OF
THE LEADERS OF THE CHARGE AHEAD
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN WHICH SAYS
THE TWIN GOALS OF ELECTRIFYING
TRANSPORTATION IN CALIFORNIA.
AND PROVIDING ACCESS TO CLEAN
MOBILITY TO ALL CALIFORNIANS. I
SERVE ON THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
TO THE ENERGY COMMISSION CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM WHICH
THIS BILL ADDRESSES. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THERE POLLUTION
FALLS DISPROPORTIONATELY ON
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND MOST OF THAT AIR
POLLUTION CONCENTRATIONS TATIAN
IN FACT THERE WERE RESOURCES
BOARD FOUND THAT 45% OF THE AIR
POLLUTION EXPOSURE DISPARITY
FOR THE BLACK POPULATION. WAS
FROM MOBILE SOURCES. SO WE ASK
YOU TO PASS THIS BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY. WE
PARTICULARLY SUPPORT IT'S A
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD REVISE THE
CRITERIA FOR THE PROGRAM TO
INCLUDE REDUCTION CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTION AND AIR TOXICS.
STANDARDS PRIORITIZATION OF
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO AGREE WITH
THE EMPHASIS ON CLEANING UP THE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
WHICH ARE EXPOSING OUR
POPULATIONS PARTICULARLY IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO
TOXIC DIESEL EXHAUST. AND WE
THANK AUTHOR FOR THE PROVISION
THAT 50% OF THE FUNDS WOULD GO
TO PROJECTS THAT ARE LOCATED IN
AND BENEFITING OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. WE
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROVIDE
TANGIBLE EQUITY MEASURABLE
ACCOUNTABLE STANDARDS FOR THE
PROGRAM WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
AUTHOR IS CONSIDERING NEWS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE DISCUSSION WITH HER AND
OTHER INTERESTED PARTIES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SO WE
DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES LISTED
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS POINT
I'LL GO TO THE CHAMBERS IS
ANYBODY IN THE CHAMBERS WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK FOR OR AGAINST
THE BILL. OKAY WITH ANYBODY TO
REMOTE HEARING I'M SPEAKING FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL. OKAY
OPERATOR WE SHOULD HAVE A TO
RESET THE CLOCK. ON THE PHONE
IN OPPOSITION FOR TWO MINUTES-
OPPOSITION STATEMENT OPERATOR
CAN YOU SEE IF THERESA COOK IS
AVAILABLE BY PHONE. ASSEMBLY
MOMENT. THIS COOK PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON THE
BILL I THREE TO COOK EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON NOW- EP THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE
I WANT TO BEGIN OUR TESTIMONY
WAY THE PERSECUTION OF THE
AUTHOR AND ON THIRD DESIRE TO
TACKLE HEAVY AND MEDIUM DUTY-
IF YOU'LL COLLECTOR VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS HYDROGEN STATION
DEVELOPERS AND HYDROGEN FUEL
PRODUCED THERE. WERE THRILLED
TO BE A PART OF THAT SOLUTION
HOWEVER THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM I THINK
ONE OF SEVERAL PROGRAMS
BENEFITING HYDROGEN MOBILITY IT
IS THE ONLY PROGRAM BENEFITING
HYDROGEN MOBILITY CANNOT AND
THEY SHIPPED PROPOSED AN EIGHTY
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE AT THE END
AND THE LIGHT DUTY HYDROGEN
MARKET STILL IN ITS INFANCY
WHAT HAPPENED DIRECTLY IMPACT
ON THE ABILITY TO GROW AND
SCALE THE HEAVY AND MEDIUM DUTY
INFRASTRUCTURE IT WILL BE
NECESSARY FOR US TO MEET OUR
TWENTY FOURTEEN THIRTY THIRTY
FIVE PEOPLE. WE SUGGESTED THAT
A DEDICATED SATISFIED OF THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
MUCH LIKE WHAT WAS DONE TEN
YEARS AGO WITH THE 20% TO ALLOW
HYDROGEN TO GROW AND TO REACH
SCALE BEFORE REACHING A POINT
AT SELF SUFFICIENCY- WE BELIEVE
YOU KNOW THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE
AND VERY WELL INTENDED BUT IT
DOESN'T FULLY RECOGNIZE THE
DEVELOPMENT PATH THAT HYDROGEN
OUT OF EIGHTY- TRANSPORTATION
FUEL IS ON THE TOP OF DOING
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ARCH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS- YOU KNOW TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE. IN THE FUTURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DO HAVE ANY
FURTHER WITH A SECOND WITH ON
THE FOR. NOT POSITION. NO I
DON'T HAVE ANYONE LA SO LET'S
OPEN UP THE FOR. IN FAVOR OR A
TO THE BILL. ALL RIGHT IF YOU
DO SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL
THESE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE USING A
TOUCH TONE PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
THE- HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING
THE NUMBERS. ONCE AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU AND OUR
FIRST QUESTION COMES FROM THE
LINE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON DILLON
JACK ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION.
WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED IN A LETTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO THE LINE
OF SEVENTY FIVE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON NATALIE KNACK FOR
DISTRICT SUPPORT FOR THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATION
NICOLETTE CORPORATION E. NOW-
NINE SYSTEM CHAIN ENERGY CHANGE
ENERGY ANAHEIM TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK VELOZ. ENERGY THE LINE
ELECTRIC COMPANY PHOENIX
MOTORCARS ARRIVAL GLOBAL GROUP
NORTH AMERICA MACK TRUCK MOTIVE
POWER SYSTEMS AB BEATING
GREENPOWER MOTOR COMPANY AND
THE MENTIONED DYNAMIC. DYNAMIC
CORPORATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND NOW TO LINES SEVENTY
NINE LINE SEVENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- GOOD AFTERNOON
JULIE MELANAU SKI BALL YEAH THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF MOVING THIS MATTER
FORWARD COMMITTEE TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
AND OUTLINES SEVENTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON MILLION MARKET WITH
THE CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE
ENERGY AND STRONG SUPPORT YEAH.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL GO
TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- FRAZIER
FONG. I THANK YOU CARE- BUT TO
THE OTHER I CERTAINLY COMING
FROM THE A ROBUST AGRICULTURE
DISTRICT I APPRECIATE YOUR
DESIRE AND- AND- TO PROVIDE
FURTHER INVESTMENTS- IN THE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY. DUTY TRUCK
SPACE I WANTED TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE THOUGH ON THE
BROADER CONCERN THAT WAS
MENTIONED ABOUT THE NEED FOR
SELF SUFFICIENCY IN THE PUSH
FOR. ONE TECHNOLOGY AND PLACING
ALL THEIR EGGS IN ONE BASKET
WHICH WOULD COULD POTENTIALLY
LIMIT FUNDS FOR OTHER EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE IN THE
CLEAN ENERGY SPACE. SUCH AS
HYDROGEN AND SO- I BELIEVE%
THERE'S A BENEFIT. TO
ENCOURAGING ALL TYPES OF NEW
ADVANCEMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
TRANSPORTATION SO I WANNA GET
YOUR THOUGHTS ON ON ON ON THAT
ISSUE. AND AND KIND OF. YOU
KNOW WHAT. THE PASSWORD CARE.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR- IN
FACT TO THE OPPOSITION FROM
HYDROGEN. WAS JUST RECENT AND
IN FACT IT WASN'T MENTIONED IN
THE ANALYSIS- BUT WE HAVE
ENGAGED IN THE MOVE BEEN
ENGAGING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS. THERE IS MUCH TO
BE SAID ABOUT USING ALL OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES AS YOU HAVE
INDICATED. HYDROGEN IS ONE OF
THOSE AND WE WILL CONTINUE OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM
ABSOLUTELY OKAY WELL I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT I'M
I'M I'M I'M I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL I JUST
WANTED TO- GET YOUR PERSPECTIVE
AND I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE
WORKING ON PROVIDING SOME.
CLEAR AND PREDICTABLE PATHS TO
SELF SUFFICIENCY BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S THE IMPORTANT AND
ABOUT THE WITH ALL THESE
INVESTMENT IS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE SELF
SUFFICIENT BUT THAT WE'RE ALSO.
DIVERSIFYING AS WELL SO- I
THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS. MR
BERMAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I JUST WANT TO. SAY THANKS
TO THE MAJORITY LEADER FOR.
BRINGING THIS PROPOSAL FORWARD-
WELL SHE MIGHT HAVE. TERRIBLE
JUDGMENT BASEBALL TEAMS YEAH
I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT SHE IS
GREAT JUDGMENT AND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION POLICY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WILL ACCEPT
THAT AS THE- AS A POSITIVE FOR
MY TEAM THE DODGERS. ANYONE
ELSE. OKAY ISRAEL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. CLEARLY WE NEED
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS TO FOCUS ON AREAS
WHERE THE POLLUTION IS THE
HIGHEST AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU CAN WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. OKAY MOTIONS DALY
SECOND BERMAN- AND I I'M
SUPPORT THE BILL THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI.
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG I BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
I DALY DALY AYE DAVIES. DAVIES
NO GIPSON. KALRA KALRA HI LEE
LEE I MEDINA. MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
WHEN. DONNA O'DONNELL I WORK.
WICKS WICKS HI. THE VOTE IS TEN
ONE THE BILL IS OUT WILL BE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY YOU
ARE NEXT IN MAY BEGIN. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THERE'S TO BE A
TABLE HERE. NOPE ANYWAY THANK
YOU IS YOUR FRIEDMAN IF THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENTS FOR MY
BILL TODAY THE CLEAN CARS
EQUITY ACT WE KNOW THE REDUCING
EMISSIONS FROM VEHICLES AND
MOBILE SOURCES AS ONE OF THE
KEY ISSUES WE NEED TO ADDRESS
AND FINING CLIMATE CHANGE. AND
ALSO CRITICAL IN OUR EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE OUR AIR QUALITY. AND AS
WELL AS I SAID ON THE EFFECTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE TODAY
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS LIVE.
IN THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE
COUNTRY AND SUFFERED THAT
SUFFER FROM ILLNESSES AND
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITION
CONDITIONS ASSOCIATED WITH AIR
POLLUTION- PASSENGER VEHICLES
AS I SAID ARE BOTH THE LARGEST
CONTRIBUTOR TO BOTH GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. SMOG AND
PARTICULATE AIR MATTERS
FLOATING IN THE AIR AND AREAS
LIKE SACRAMENTO. CALIFORNIA
LEADS AND LEADS THE NATION. IN
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES OPTION
BUT WE STILL NEED A TEN FOLD
INCREASE IN VADS TO MEET THE
GOAL OF FIVE MILLION. THAT ON
THE ROAD BY TWENTY THIRTY AND A
100% OF THAT SALES BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. THIS BILL HELPS
THE STATE ACHIEVE THIS GOAL IN
TWO WAYS FIRST IT WILL PROMOTE-
THE RAPID AND ACHAL EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION. OF REBATES BY
OFFERING LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
CONSUMERS- FINANCIAL RESOURCES
TO PURCHASE THESE VEHICLES
THROUGH EXISTING TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROGRAMS WHERE YOU KNOW
THAT REBATES ARE PROVEN. TOOL
OF PROMOTING ADOPTION THE POWER
OF ECONOMICS. AND INCENTIVES
HOWEVER JUST LAST WEEK WITH THE
AIRPORT ANNOUNCED THAT IN ONE
MONTH WILL BE NO MONEY LEFT.
FOR A CURRENT CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM WITH QUESTIONS
ON THE VIABILITY. OF OUR CAP
AND. TRADE FUNDS AS MANY OF YOU
ARE AWARE. THERE IS CURRENTLY
NOT ENOUGH MONEY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR TO
CONTINUE THIS. IN THIS BILL CAN
HELP ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THE
PROVIDE QUICK CRITICAL REBATE
FUNDING. AND FURTHER SPUR-
ACTIVITY FROM CONSUMERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SECOND IT WE WILL BE
ENSURING THAT THE AIR POLLUTION
AND CLIMATE IMPROVEMENTS MADE
BY INCREASING ADOPTION OF THE
VEHICLES ARE NOT CANCELLED OUT
AGAIN ARE NOT CANCELED OUT. BY
THE SALE OF MORE POLLUTING
VEHICLES. BECAUSE EVERY
PURCHASE OF A NEW GAS POWERED
VEHICLE REPRESENTS OVER EIGHTY
THOUSAND KILOGRAMS OF FUTURE
CARBON DIOXIDE EMISSIONS OVER
ITS LIFETIME. WHICH MEANS
EARNESTLY PROMOTING THAT SALES
TODAY- COULD NOT BE MORE
SIGNIFICANT. MANY AUTOMAKERS
MANY AUTOMAKERS HAVE MADE
PLEDGES TO SELL THE ADS IN THE
NEXT TEN FIFTEEN YEARS AND WE
APPLAUD. THIS BILL SIMPLY FALL
THESE PLEDGES AND FOLLOWS THE
ADAGE OF- RUN A REAGAN- AND YOU
KNOW TRUST BUT VERIFY SO WE
HOPE THAT THIS TRIGGER WILL
NEVER HAPPEN AND THERE'S A LOT
OF FEAR ABOUT WHAT THE IMPACT
OF THIS BUT WE CERTAINLY HOPE
THAT. THIS WON'T HAPPEN I THINK
THE GOALS OF YOUR RESULT WHICH
WE CAN ADDRESS A LASTLY BY
POVERTY BY PROVIDING- AN
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
REBATES ON PASSENGER VEHICLES
WILL BE ABLE TO USE STATE
MONEY. TO INVEST IN A CLEAN
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
AND CLEAN MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES TESTIFYING WITH ME
TODAY ARE BILL MCGOVERN WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR.
AND DAVID REICH MET A SENIOR
ENGINEER. OF THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS THANK YOU
VENTURE. THANK YOU AND BELIEVE
BOTH YOUR WITNESSES ARE ON THE
PHONE- SO OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE BRING US MISTER MY
GOVERNOR MR RIGHT CONNECT
WHATEVER'S GOING FIRST. GO
AHEAD AND- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BILL MCGOVERN
WITH THE COALITION OF CLEAN
AIR- IN SUPPORT OF THE GREEN
CARS EQUITY ACT AS MR MCCARTY
JUST STATED AND AS WE
DISCUSSED- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REGISTERS BILL JUST NOW. MOBILE
SOURCES ARE THE LEADING CAUSE
OF AIR POLLUTION AND GREENHOUSE
GAS POLLUTION IN CALIFORNIA BY
FAR. AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THOSE IMPACTS ARE BORNE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BY OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. YEAH
IT IS USUALLY THE MEMBERS OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES WHO ARE LEAST
ABLE TO AFFORD CLEAN MOBILITY.
AND THERE IS AN UP FRONT COST
DISPARITY BETWEEN CONVENTIONAL
VEHICLES AND THE CLEANEST
VEHICLES AND THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS THE DISPARITY. THE UC
DAVIS INSTITUTE FOR
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES FOUND
THAT THIS SORT OF MECHANISM
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY PROVIDE A
DISINCENTIVE FOR BUYING MORE
POLLUTING VEHICLES AND ALSO
GIVE BUYERS AN INCENTIVE TO
PURCHASE CLEANER VEHICLES BY
MAKING THEM CHEAPER. IF FOUND
UNDER ONE SCENARIO THAT IF THE
pLOW INCOME CONSUMERS SWITCHES
FROM A THIRTY MILE PER GALLON
SEDAN TO A FORTY FIVE MILE PER
GALLON HYBRID. THAT CONSUMER
WOULD RECEIVE A FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR REBATE AND GARNER FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FUEL
SAVINGS OVER THE LIFE OF THE
CAR. ALSO FOUND THAT THE
MECHANISM WOULD IMPROVE SOCIAL
EQUITY BY REDUCING THE COST OF
VEHICLES FOR LOWER INCOME
BUYERS. AS MUCH MCCARTY STATED
THIS BILL COULD REPLACE THE
STATE MONEY THAT IS CURRENTLY
USED FOR VEHICLE INCENTIVES
LIKE QUEEN VEHICLE REBATE
PROJECT WHICH IS CURRENTLY.
RUNNING OUT OF MONEY. AND IT
ALSO WOULD FUNDS. EQUITY
PROJECTS THAT ARE ALSO STRAPPED
FOR FUNDS RIGHT NOW WELL LIKE
CLEAN. AND AN OLDER POLLUTING
CAR AND GET INTO AN ADVANCE
CLEAN CAR. LIKE THE CLEAN
VEHICLE ASSISTANCE PROJECT THAT
PROVIDES GRANTS AND LOANS FOR
LOW INCOME BUYERS TO GET INTO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES YOUR TIME IS
THE ONLY OPTION WE CAN FINISH
UP YOUR YOUR TWO MINUTES ARE UP
IF YOU CAN JUST FINISH UP.
THINGS I WILL ABSOLUTELY GET
ALSO FINANCED PROJECTS THAT
ALLOW FOR NON VEHICLE OWNING
TYPES OF CLEAN MOBILITY THAT
WOULD ALSO HELP US REDUCE CLEAN
UP REDUCE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID AIKMAN NINE
THE SENIOR ENGINEER WITH THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS.
AND I AM PLEASED TO SPEAK TODAY
REPORT AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN WHICH
ESTABLISHES A SELF SUSTAINING
FUND TO INCREASE THE SALES OF
ZERO EMISSION PASSENGER CARS
AND TRUCKS IN THE STATE. OF
CALIFORNIA IS A PARTY SEEING
THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
WITH DROUGHT. HEATWAVES AND
UNPRECEDENTED WILDFIRES. AND WE
KNOW THAT WE MUST GREATLY
REDUCE EMISSIONS. TO SLOW THE
RATE OF CLIMATE CHANGE. THIS IS
MARK. SINGLE SOURCE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE EMISSIONS IN THE STATE
IS TRANSPORTATION. SO THE VITAL
THE CALIFORNIA TAKE ACTION
BOOKSELLERS TO SWITCH FROM
PETROLEUM FUEL CARS TRUCKS. THE
CLEANER ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE AIR
POLLUTION FROM GASOLINE CARS
AND TRUCKS HARMS THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIANS EXPOSURE TO AIR
POLLUTION IS INEQUITABLE. WITH
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR EXPOSED
THE HIGHER AMOUNTS OF AIR
POLLUTION FROM ON ROAD VEHICLES.
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP ON
CLEAN UP TRANSPORTATION IS
IMPORTANT. ABOUT TWO MILLION
NEW CARS SOLD EACH YEAR IN THE
STATE IN TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S
MADE UP ABOUT 80% OF ALL NEW
VEHICLES SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
MEETING THAT GOAL OF A 100%
THAT FAILED IN JUST FIFTEEN
YEARS TIME WILL REQUIRE
INNOVATIVE POLICIES SUCH AS AB
TWELVE EIGHTEEN. AN INCREASE
INCENTIVES FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES FUNDED BY AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN WILL HELP SPEED A MORE
EQUITABLE TRANSITION TO CLEAN
VEHICLES. AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN
CREATION OF SELF SUSTAINING
PROGRAM WILL ALLOW CLEAN CAR
PROGRAMS TO OPERATE WITH MORE
CERTAINTY INCREASING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE EFFORTS.
YOU SEE A SUPPORTABLE OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTEEN AND THANKS THE
OFFER FOR THE LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
FIRST WE HAVE HEARD FOR
AUGUSTINE WHO WAS ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
BRING MR AUGUSTINE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD SIR. YES THANK YOU- CHAIR
REMEMBERS MY NAME IS KURT
AUGUSTINE I'M THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF POLICY FOR THE
ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION WHICH IS A TRADE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS 99%
OF THE AUTO MAKERS WHO ARE
SELLING PEOPLE DENIED STATE AS
WELL AS MANY OF THE TECHNOLOGY
PROVIDERS- THAT GO INTO THOSE
VEHICLES. WHAT WE ARE OPPOSED
TO AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN BUT NOT
BASED ON THE QUESTION OF A DEBT
FUTURE FOR ALL THE FUTURE OF
THE AUTO INDUSTRY IS ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AT A STRONG
ROBUST MARKET FOR ALL SEGMENTS
OF OUR SOCIETY ARE CRUCIAL THAT
SUCCESS SO WE SHARE THE GOAL OF
THE SPONSORS AND THE WITNESSES
THAT WE HEARD BUT THIS BILL IS
NOT THE ANSWER. TO THAT GOAL.
THIS BILL A- BARBECUE STAY. IN
GOALS FOR EMISSIONS THAT ARE
NOT BASED ON ANY SCIENCE OR
DATA. AND THEN IT TURNS AROUND
AND FINDS COMPANIES FOR NOT
MEETING THOSE STANDARDS.
ADDITIONALLY THESE FINES ARE
OPEN ENDED WITH NO STATUTORY
LIMITS. AND ARE SUBJECT TO THE
WHIMS OF THE FOLKS WHO WANT TO
RECUPERATE THIS MONEY. IT IS
UNCLEAR TO AUTOMAKERS HOW
FINING AUTO MANUFACTURERS BASED
ON CONSUMERS PURCHASES
INCENTIVIZES STAFF PURCHASES
AND ANYWAY. I'D BEEN STATED
THIS CALL IS FOR THE FUNDING OF
REBATES. BUT THIS BILL NOT
NECESSARY TO DO THAT THE
PROGRAM AND FUNDING MECHANISMS
ARE ALREADY IN STATUTE AND IN
PRACTICE TODAY AND IN FACT
THEY'RE BEING DISCUSSED WITHIN
THE LEGISLATURE CURRENTLY AS WE
SPEAK. WE ENDORSE THE
CONTINUATION OF THESE PROGRAMS
WHICH HELP CONSUMERS IN
NUMEROUS ECONOMIC SITUATIONS
ARE STATE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE INCENTIVES. IN ADDITION
TO BE IN CONFLICT WITH THAT
GOAL THIS BILL IS ALSO IN
CONFLICT WITH THE UNDERGO
ONGOING NEGOTIATIONS FOR A ONE
NATIONAL PROGRAM THE KEY TO
CONTINUE THE DEAL THAT WAS
STRUCK WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA. BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD. THE UNITED
AUTO WORKERS AND AUTO MAKERS
FOR A GREENHOUSE GAS AND FUEL
ECONOMY STANDARDS WE ARE
CURRENTLY NEGOTIATING WITH
PRESIDENT FIGHTING TO WITHSTAND
THAT CURRENT PROGRAM HOW FOR
DECADES PLUS OR MORE CAN SOME
UP MR. FINISHED YES THANK YOU
YEAH THANK YOU AND SO WE AGREED.
WHAT DOES PROGRAM BUT MUCH WORK
IS NEEDED WE DO NEED A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM TO TAKE A
LOOK AT TO MEET THAT GOAL OF
WHICH IS STATED WITH A PERCENT
OF VEHICLE THAT A 12100%
INCREASE WE DO NEED A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM BUT THIS
IS NOT THE WAY TO GO THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE JIM
JEFFERIES I BELIEVE IN THE
CHAMBERS. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRWOMAN FRIEDMAN
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE I MISS
TIMOTHY JEFFRIES I'M A POWER
BETTER YOUR NICEST RECORD
TWELVE YEARS HAVING SERVED.
CURRENTLY I AM A- I GRADUATED
PRETTY PREVENTABLE MAKERS
CURRENTLY I'M A BUSINESS
MANAGER SECRETARY CHARGEABLE TO
MAKE IT LOOK A LOT FIVE POINT
NINE. PITTSBURG CALIFORNIA
SEVEN FORCED. BEFORE YOUR TO
DATE OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN. WE UNDERSTAND THIS
COUNTRY'S UNDERTAKEN A GREAT
TRANSITION AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
REMOVE REMOVED FROM TRYING THIS
TRADITIONAL FORMS OF FOSSIL
FUELS TO MORE SUSTAINABLE FORMS
OF ENERGY. AND THE BOILERMAKERS
PLAN BE IMPORTANT PART OF THE
TRANSITION. AT THE BOILERMAKERS
WE HAVE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT
OF EVOLVING TECHNOLOGY FOR
GENERATIONS. AND TODAY WE ARE
POISED TO START BUILDING NEW
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES AND
CONVERT EXISTING FACILITIES TO
CREATE VERY LOW EMISSION. FUMES
WE ARE ACTUALLY IN THE PROCESS
OF CONVERTING TO FOSSIL FUEL
REFINERIES IN THE BAY AREA TO
HYDROGEN AND BIOFUEL
REFINERIES. ONE B. MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA. ALSO IN VEGAS HERE
WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT TO BUILD A
FACILITY THAT WILL CONVERT
PLANT SEED TO BIOFUEL.
IMPAIRMENT LOSS AND IS
CALIFORNIA WE'RE ABOUT TO BUILD
A PLANT. THAT WILL CONVERT
POLICY MASK TO CHECK. ALL THESE
INCREDIBLE CREDIBLE EXAMPLES OF
CALIFORNIA'S INNOVATION
PRODUCING NEW CLEAN LOW
EMISSION FUELS OF ENERGY. TO
POWER CALIFORNIA'S CARS AND
TRUCKS. THIS INNOVATION WILL
ALSO ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO BE A
LEADER IN THE NEXT GENERATION
OF CLEAN FUELS. AND THIS
INNOVATION WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY POWER THEIR CARS
AND TRUCKS TO GET. TO AND FROM
SCHOOL AND WORK BUT THERE'S A
PROBLEM. THE PROBLEM IS THIS
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHT
TWELVE EIGHTY. THIS BILL WILL
KILL ALL THE CLEAN FUEL
INNOVATION THAT IS CURRENTLY
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THIS DEAL WAS THIS BILL
SEEKS TO LEGISLATE OUT OF
EXISTENCE THE INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE. AND NOT
ALLOW FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CLEAN FUELS OR FEELS THAT CAN
UTILIZED INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINE. CURRENTLY OUR ELECTRIC
ELECTRICAL GRID IS NOT IN A
POSITION TO POWERFULLY CLOSE TO
THE SIZE. EVEN IF WE BUILT TWO
TIMES THE OF THE- EXISTING
POWER PLANTS. WE CANNOT HAVE
THAT WE COULD NOT HAVE THE
POWER TO SHOW THAT THIS LOW. TO
NAME A CALIFORNIA LITTLE LEAGUE
COME. FITTED CONTAINABLE
FORWARD CREATE A BROADER SENSE
OF LATE OF THIS LENS. TAKES TO
ACCOUNT NEW FUELS BIOFUELS
HYDROGEN. NATURAL GAS WHO KNOWS
WHAT'S NEXT. FRIENDS AND I KNOW
PEOPLE THAT I KNOW. SOMETIMES
LEAD TO DIFFERENT PEOPLE I LOOK
LIKE WE DON'T ON ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. THANK YOU MA'AM YOU
HAVE A GOOD DAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO HAVE ANY NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO. THE ME TOO
SECTION OF OUR- PEOPLE
SPEAKING. IN FAVOR AND OPPOSED
TO HAVE ANYBODY IN THE CHAMBERS
TWENTY TO SPEAK ON THIS MEASURE.
WITH ANYONE IN THE WITNESS
ROOMS. OKAY OPERATOR COMPLETES
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK FOR OR
AGAINST AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE. AND OUR FIRST. LINE IS
LINE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THEY DISCONNECTED I'M
SORRY AND BY TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND ANSWER THAT-
WE'RE OPPOSED TO AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN I MANY CANAL MODERATE
FACTORS COUNTY BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
CAN OPPOSITION. TO TWELVE
EIGHTEEN AND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY
NAME'S JEFF HUNTER LAW COME-
THE SECRETARY TREASURER OF THE
HUMBOLDT DEL NORD WILLING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES IN THE
DISTRICT RAP. FOR THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE WE STAND
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE EIGHTEEN ALONG WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE MAN SAN DIEGO BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION. YEAH BY
STATE BUILDING DURING THE BY TO
THE WRAPS. THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINE SEVENTY TWO. ROBERTSDALE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FIGURES
ALLIED TRADES DISTRICT COUNCIL
THIRTY SIX IN STRONG OPPOSITION
STANDING WITH THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NOW TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND.
THREE ONE OH THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE CHANGE
THEREAFTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABORS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND IT IS ALSO SMART
PEOPLE WORKERS LOCAL ONE ZERO
FIVE ANYWAY THE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND
NOW TO LINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY
MEMBERS ALEX JACKSON ON BEHALF
OF ENERGY THE STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE GOLDEN VISION OF AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN ASCARI VOTE KEEP
WORKING ON THE MECHANICS THANK.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
THIRTY FIVE. YOU'RE NEVER GOING
TO MATCH WHAT MUHAMMAD THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION TO TWELVE
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE FIFTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WILLIAM
GONZALEZ WITH THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES AND WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE THE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
SIXTY SIX IS YOUR PHONE ON MUTE.
LINE. SIXTY SIX. WE WILL MOVE
ALONG TO LINE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE SEVENTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE CATHOLIC FROM THE
POLITICAL KNOWN COUNTING AND
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO THE BILL WHAT
IT WILL DO TO THE RULE
COMPLETELY. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE FIFTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MY NAME
IS KEN MILLER HIRE WORKERS
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY AND WE
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND OUTLINED FORTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JEFF ROBERTS WOULD DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN LOCAL YOU NEED
TO NINETY FOUR INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES IN OPPOSITION WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRICKS. THANK
YOU SIR AND NOW TO LINE TWENTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON NOT TO
GAINES POLITICAL DIRECTOR OF
THE OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
NUMBER TWELVE STANDING WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINE THIRTY SIX. YES MY NAME IS
GREG CARLIN I'M THE ORGANIZER
AN APPRENTICESHIP SHARE WITH
THE ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS LOCAL
LAKE AND WE OPPOSE AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINE SIXTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JASON LINDSAY HOW
FROM IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT AND WE OPPOSE
TWELVE EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
EIGHTY FIVE. HELLO HI THIS IS
MITCHELL BECHTEL IRON WORKERS
LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES. THANK YOU AND
NOW TO LINE SIXTY FOUR. THIRTY
BOILED IN BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
ACT PROCESSORS THAT THE ASIAN
AMERICAN STATURE GROWS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE SIXTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS CAROL
KANE CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AND WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS EXPRESSED THEIR
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
THIRTY SEVEN. BERMAN DONALD THE
LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL AND WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTEEN THANK YOU FOR
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU
ESPECIALLY WITH THE FISHING IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU N.
OUTLINED ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR.
FLORIDA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
NINETY EIGHT. AFTER THE MEMBERS
CHENEY HOP WITH THE CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AN OUTLINE. EIGHTY TWO. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS COREY
VAN RICE THE FINANCIAL
SECRETARY TREASURER OF THE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OF STANISLAUS
WOLLEMI MARIPOSA AND MERCED
COUNTIES WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND OUTLINED. TWENTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M BILL PRESS
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY FOR EXAMPLE
DO YOU DON'T RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SPELLING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
CAL HOLE WHICH DEMONSTRATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU
AN OUTLINE ONE HUNDRED AND TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MATT KREMIN SHALL BE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE EIGHTEEN. MY
NAME'S CURTIS DAY DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES LOCAL TWELVE AND
WE STAND IN OPPOSITION WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE ONE HUNDRED AND ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR I'M
RON MILLER DALY ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES ON BEHALF OF
THE HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
SKILLED AND TRAINED MEN AND
WOMEN OF THE BUILDING TRADES
AFFILIATES WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION. TO TWELVE EIGHTEEN
ALONG WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE.
EIGHTY THREE. EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE WILL MOVE
ALONG TO LINE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD NINETY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON SCHERING
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NICK
HARVEY WITH LOCAL ONE FOURTEEN
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AS IT
WILL HURT JOBS IN HER GOOD
UNION WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NOW TO LINE. FORTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIN
BOSTON BUSINESS MANAGER OF
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
FOUR EIGHT FOUR IN VENTURA WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF. AB
TWELVE EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN OUTLINE NINETY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON OUR CAKE FOR A
LOCAL THIRTY FARMERS AND
PIPEFITTER SAN FRANCISCO WE ARE
JOINED THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN THEIR OPPOSITION TO
AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT. HELLO MY NAME HE
ROCKED THEM WITH THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA ACTION AND N BEHALF
OF MORE THAN OUR OF OUR NINETY
THOUSAND SUPPORTERS I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU
AND OUTLINED. FORTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON GLOBAL MINE WORKERS
UNION LOCAL THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT- GETTING IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN ALONGSIDE
THE BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
NINETY SEVEN. BUT AFTERNOON
GETTING RIGHT BUMMER SOME
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL TWO FOUR SIX
REPRESENTING FRESNO MADERA AND
KINGS AND TULARE COUNTIES IT
DIDN'T TRONG OPPOSITION
STANDING WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE ONE HUNDRED. BACKING A
NIGHT MIKE GREATLY WITH THIS
ACCOUNT SIXTEEN GREATER
KNOWLEDGE RATE COMES DOWN THE
BILL INSURANCE OPPOSITION OF AB
ONE TWO ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE. SIXTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S SCOTT
BILL REPRESENTING THE PLUMBERS
OF LOCAL POOR SIX SEVEN AND SAN
MATTEO COUNTY AND I AM DOING
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
OUTLINED THIRTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ROD BREWER FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON- HEARING
SUPPORT FOR AB. TWELVE EIGHTY.
THANK YOU AND OUTLINES FORTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY CHAMPION WITH
THE OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
TWELVE WE STAND THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE THIRTY. YES HI WHEN A
RENTAL LEGAL I'M A DISTRICT UP
TO SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE BILL
ENTRIES IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE NINETY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MICHAEL
CERA GOES ON BEHALF OF THE
LATIN BUSINESS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOHN SPALDING SECTOR THE
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL IN KERN
INYO AND MONO COUNTIES. AND WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE EIGHTY THANK. THANK YOU
AN OUTLINE FIFTY THREE. OKAY.
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE WILL MOVE ALONG KLEIN FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
OUR NEXT DOOR BONUS WHAT THE
LABORS INTERNATIONAL UNION
PACIFIC SOUTHWEST REGION
COVERING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE JOINED THE
BILL STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
THEIR OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN
MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF THE MILK
PRODUCERS COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU SO WITH THAT WE WILL RETURN
NOW TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MISTER
MEDINA. THANK YOU AS A- PROUD
CO AUTHOR I WANTED TO- SAY SOME
REMARKS ACCORDING THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION. TWENTY
NINETEEN STATE OF THE AIR
REPORT CARD RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WHICH MY DISTRICT IS AN
RECEIVED AN F. GRADE- IN THAT
REPORT IN THE SAME REPORT
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WAS IN THE TOP
TEN COUNTIES FOR MOST AT RISK.
OR YEAR ROUND PARTICULATE
POLLUTION IN FACT ACCORDING TO
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH RIVERSIDE COUNTY IS
PREVALENCE OF ASTHMA WAS
FIFTEEN POINT 7% SLIGHTLY
HIGHER THAN THE STATE'S FIFTEEN
POINT FOUR PREVALENCE. SO ALL
THIS IS TO SAY THAT WE HAVEN'T
DONE ENOUGH AND WE NEED TO DO
MORE. GIVEN THAT RIVERSIDE IS
USED AS A MAJOR TRUCK FREIGHT
AND COMMUTER CORRIDOR.
POLLUTANTS FROM THESE
EMISSIONS. POSE A GREATER
HEALTH RISKS TO MY CONSTITUENTS
CONSTITUENTS. REDUCING
DANGEROUS PARTICULATE MATTER BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES NOT ONLY
BENEFITS RIVERSIDE WITH THE
STATE AS A WHOLE. THE SOONER WE
INCREASE MASS ADOPTION AND FORD
ABILITY OF SAID VEHICLES THE
BETTER. I THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SACRAMENTO IN PALO ALTO.
IN THIS BILL FOR AND I ASK MY
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE HI. THANK
YOU MISTER O'DONNELL. YES SIR
THANK YOU A MANAGER MY FIRST.
JUST QUESTION I'M LOOKING TO
THE ANALYSIS OF THE NEVER SEEN
THIS IN AN ANALYSIS BEFORE. THE
TALKS ABOUT SUPPORTING AND
CONCEPT. SO THEY DON'T SUPPORT
THE BILL BECAUSE THE NOW SO
SHOULD BE ABOUT THE BILL NOT
CONCEPTS I MEAN I SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT OF WHAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY IN FACT I THINK. MANY OF
THOSE IN OPPOSITION SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT OF MAYBE NOT THE BILL.
SO COULD COULD I GET SOME
CLARIFICATION ON FROM THE
AUTHOR OR FOR ME OR I JUST
DON'T KNOW WHAT SUPPORT AND
CONCEPT. MEANS IN THE CONTEXT
OF AN ANALYSIS. WELL I CAN
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF STAFF-
BECAUSE I WORK WITH THEM ON BUT
THE ANALYSIS WAS GOING TO SAY.
AND BASICALLY WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO
CONTINUE FUNDING- SEVEN SEVEN
SENTENCE. AND WHILE WE THINK
THAT THIS BILL DOES HAVE- THERE
ARE CONCERNS BUT WE FELT THAT
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE
THIS IMPORTANT CONVERSATION- SO
THAT'S- KIND OF WHERE THE
SUPPORTING THE CONCEPT RIGHT WE
SEE THIS BILL AS BEING
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE WORKED ON AS IT
MOVES THROUGH OUR HOUSE AND
THROUGH THE SENATE. AND SO WE
WERE JUST SUGGESTING THAT THE-
AUTHOR CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS TO WORD OF
LABOR TO WORK WITH KERR- TO TRY
TO- FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY. TO
APPROACH THIS VERY IMPORTANT
GOAL OF CONTINUING TO FUND
SEVEN CENTERS OKAY. GREAT JUST
AS A MEMBER JUST ONE OTHER. BY
MIKE MY CONCERN THAT WE START
ABOUT SUPPORTING THINGS IN
CONCEPT IT SHOULD REALLY BE
ABOUT THE BILL ITSELF I DO
AGAIN SUPPORT THE CONCEPT I
REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT'S
PROBABLY DONE MORE THAN ANY
OTHER IN THE STATE. TO REDUCE
MOBILE SOURCES OF AIR POLLUTION
BECAUSE I HAVE THE TWO PORTS. I
SAW A MAJOR FREEWAY THAT RUNS
THROUGH IT SO I WELL KNOW THEY
NEED. TO CLEAN OUR AIR I DON'T
KNOW THAT THIS BILL TO I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
BECAUSE I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE BECAUSE
NOTABLE HONOR TO IS ANOTHER
REVIEWED. ARTICLE LISTED ON HER
WHO TYPICALLY ARE STAKEHOLDERS
IN DISCUSSIONS LIKE THESE AND I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S DESIRE
TO MOVE THE CONVERSATION
FORWARD. BUT I JUST THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE MUCH MORE
STAKEHOLDER INPUT. IN THIS
EFFORT- SO WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
AGAIN I DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
HOW THIS WOULD IMPACT THE
WORKING CLASSES THOSE ARE THE
FOLKS THAT BY. THE KIND OF
VEHICLES THIS TARGETS TO SOME
EXTENT. AND I BELIEVE I WOULD
MAKE THE MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE.
AND THAT IS A PROBLEM FOR ME.
TO JUST TARGET THOSE
HARDWORKING FOLKS BECAUSE THE
TYPES OF VEHICLES THEY HAVE TO
BUY ARE TYPICALLY. NO HEAVIER
DUTY IF YOU WILL THAN A THAN
JUST A SIMPLE PASSENGER
VEHICLE. SO THAT I AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S- DESIRE
TO MOVE THE CONVERSATION
FORWARD I CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL BUT I DO SUPPORT CONCEPT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WE WITH YOU MADAM CHAIR I
SUPPORT THE CONCEPT AS WELL AND
I THINK IT'S CRITICAL FOR US TO
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS.
BECAUSE THIS IS WHERE WE NEED
TO HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS-
ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE GOVERNOR
AND THE VISION HE'S TRYING
OUTLINED BUT- DOING SOMETHING
THROUGH. A EXECUTIVE ORDER
DOESN'T NECESSARILY. ALLOW THE
DEBATE AND THE DISCUSSION AND
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE NEED
TO ADEQUATELY PROVIDE SO I
ACTUALLY THINK THE AUTHOR OR
THE AUTHOR'S FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND I DO THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS THE
APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR US TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION. AND I
GUESS I. YEAH I HAVE A FOR A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS BECAUSE-
TODAY I WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BUT. YOU KNOW WHAT WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING HOW YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS EVEN I BELIEVE
CARP HAS LESS RESTRICTIVE-
AVENUES OF GETTING TO THEIR
GOALS AND IN THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S BEEN EXPEDITED WHEN YOU
LOOK AT YOU KNOW THE 10% LOWER
THAN THE BASELINE BETWEEN
2322530% LOWER THAN BASELINE
BETWEEN TWENTY SIX TO TWENTY
NINE BUT THEN INSTEAD OF WHAT
CARD RECOMMENDS THAT 40% THIS
BILL JUMPS UP TO SIXTY PERCENT.
FOR IT TWENTY THIRTY TO TWENTY
THIRTY FOUR SO IF THE AUTHOR
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT I'D
BE INTERESTED TO HEAR- HOW.
REALISTIC THAT'S GONNA BE AND
ALSO WHAT IMPACT- THAT ARE ARE
GONNA BE FELT BECAUSE AS THE
THAT AS MY PREVIOUS COLLEAGUE
SPOKE FROM LONG BEACH THERE IS
A CONCERN ABOUT HOW. THE OLD
TECHNOLOGY DOVE TAILS WITH THE
NEW TECHNOLOGY AND IN THAT
PROCESS YOU DON'T WANT THE
BURDEN OF THAT COST BEING
PASSED DOWN TO CONSUMERS- AND-
IF THE IF MADAM CHAIR WILL
ALLOW I HAVE A SECOND QUESTION
AS WELL. LET THE AUTHOR RESPOND
TO THIS ONE FIRST. SURE I THINK
THAT THE QUESTION AS FAR AS
THESE- THRESHOLD NUMBERS IN
HERE VERSUS CARP AND THINK THAT
CHANGE THE LAST FEW YEARS IF
NOT MONTHS- SEVERAL LARGE AUTO
MANUFACTURERS INCLUDING GENERAL
MOTORS SAID A VERY LOFTY PLAN
TO GET TO ONE HUNDRED PERCENT-
NON INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINES
IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS SIMPLY
NOT. NOT TEN YEARS TO TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. SO WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE IS THE THING OKAY
DON'T JUST TELL US SHOW US AND
GIVE IT'S A VERY WE THINK.
QUANTIFIABLE MARKERS AND THE
TENT BECAUSE IT ALSO SAYS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE NEED TO
BE 10% LOWER THAN BASELINE TO
BASELINE IS NOT TODAY. WHEN THE
BILL COMES IT BECOMES EFFECTIVE
THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO THE
BASS LINE IS TWENTY TWENTY
FIRST ST GOING BACK TO TWENTY
TWENTY BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE
NEED TO BE TEN PERCENT. LOWER
ANY CAN OVERALL EMISSIONS FROM
YOUR FLEET. SO DON'T JUST TELL
US SHOW US SHOWS THAT YOU'RE
DOING AND STEPPING UP- I KNOW
THE OPPOSITION TO RACISM
ARGUMENT TO THIS IN THE IN THE
LATER. YEARS AS WELL WE GO TO
THIRTY SIX PERCENT. YOU KNOW
THESE ARE THREE THRESHOLD THE
NUMBERS THAT WE'D BE WILLING TO
NEGOTIATE BUT THE GOAL HERE IS
CALIFORNIA SHE REALLY PUSHED.
THE INDUSTRY NOT TO JUST TELL
US THEY'RE DOING THIS BUT
REALLY HAVE SOME. QUANTIFIABLE
MARKERS TO MAKE SURE WE GET TO-
YOU KNOW OUR CLEANER GOALS IN
CALIFORNIA. IT IS VERY TO
ANOTHER QUESTION. I DO I- I
THINK I STILL HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ON THIS FIRST ONE AS
WELL BUT I DON'T WANT TO TAKE
UP ALL THE TIME. IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO CONTINUE WORKING ON- I
AM CONCERNED THAT THERE IS
GOING TO BE SOME- AND IMPACT
FELT AMONG CERTAIN DEMOGRAPHICS
THAT- WE NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF
AND NO AMOUNT OF COMPENSATION.
TO ALLOW THE NEW GENERATION OF
FOLKS BECOME. CLEANER VEHICLE
DRIVERS IS GONNA SUFFICE
POTENTIALLY WITHIN CERTAIN
DEMOGRAPHICS I. MAYBE YOU CAN
SPEAK TO THIS BUT I JUST. MADE
AND MAYBE I'M TRYING TO GET
INTO THE WEEDS TOO MUCH BUT I
FEEL LIKE THERE'S GOING TO BE A
SUB GROUP THAT'S GOING TO BE.
SEVERELY IMPACTED AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THAT'S GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED- LET ME JUST GET TO
THE SECOND QUESTION. OF JUST TO
CLARIFY BY THE WAY THERE THERE
WILL BE PENALTIES FOR SELLING
BUT NOT FOR PRODUCING. AND IF
THAT'S CORRECT THAT SOMEONE. IN
MY HUMBLE VIEW WEAKENS THE
ARGUMENT OF WHERE WE STAND AS A
STATE AS WELL SO I'M NOT SAYING
WE SHOULD- BAND- PRODUCTION OUT
RIGHT WORK PENALIZE THE
PRODUCTION AS WELL BECAUSE
THAT'S THE JOB MARKET BUT BUT
IT'S ALSO INTERESTING HOW WE
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO BE WILLING
TO. PENALIZE THE SELLING BUT
NOT THE PRODUCTION SO IF YOU.
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO COMMENT TO
THOSE I. HAPPY TO TAKE IT.
WITHOUT ANY MORE QUESTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. YEAH
THERE THERE'S A FEW THINGS
THERE AS FAR AS THE IMPACT ON
CONSUMERS. WELL FIRST OF ALL WE
HOPE THAT THIS PENALTY WILL
NEVER COME TO FRUITION THERE IS
A GREAT. S. ABILITY AND WE HOPE
BY NUDGING. THE INDUSTRY TODAY
WILL GIVE THEM A COUPLE YEARS
TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON WHAT THEIR
PLANS ARE TO CREATE MORE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES SOLD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO JUST ON THE
NATURAL HALF OF THE OTHER
MANUFACTURERS WON'T HAVE THIS
IMPACT AT ALL YOU KNOW THEY
WOULD JUST BE BENEFIT LOAN CAN
CONSUMERS WILL BE ABLE TO BUY
ZERO MICHIGAN VEHICLES. AT A
LOWER RATE OUR GOAL IS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF REBATES
OUT THERE ARE POTENTIALLY
INCREASE THEY GET THE AMOUNTS
TO MAKE THEM EVEN MORE VIABLE
TO FURTHER SUPPORT SPUR
INTERESTED SO I THINK. IT'S THE
OPPOSITE. OKAY ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU MANAGER
I'D LIKE TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES
FROM. THE GLENDALE. SANTA ANA
SORRY YOUR GLENDALE. GREAT
START I'D LIKE TO ECHO HIS
SENTIMENTS- YOU KNOW I'M GLAD
TO SEE. YOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS I'M GLAD TO SEE THE
LEGISLATURE TAKEN THE BALL BACK
IN TERMS OF POLICY MAKING
ESPECIALLY ON THESE BIG ISSUES
THAT WERE GOING TO STRUGGLE.
WITH TO MEET OUR CHRONICLES
AND- I HAD TO SORT OF IN
RELATED QUESTIONS AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE SIMILAR- TO. WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM LONG BEACH
WAS COMMENTING BUT I'M CURIOUS
AS TO WHETHER. I MEAN THE FIRST
ISSUE SORT OF CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CURSED ME IF
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO A HIGH
ADOPTION RATE OF SAYS- WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. ESPECIALLY WITH
MODELS OBSERVES THAT ARE MORE
LIMITED IN TERMS OF THEIR
RANGE- IS ADEQUATE AND
UNDERPINNING THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WERE. PRODUCING ENOUGH
ELECTRICITY ENOUGH ELECTRONS.
AND THAT WE HAVE A WAY TO DO
THAT. IN A WAY THAT'S A
POSITIVE IN TERMS OF GHG
EMISSIONS FREE- PRODUCTION
SOURCES AND- SITTING ON THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
FOR FOUR YEARS I'M NOT SURE
THAT WE REALLY DO HAVE A PLAN
TO DO THAT. I'M SKEPTICAL THAT
WE DO SO MY FIRST QUESTION IS.
HAS ANY THOUGHT BEEN GIVEN HAS
BEEN STUDIED. IS THERE SOME
SORT OF STUDY OR SOMETHING
SOMETHING TO POINT TO SUGGEST.
WHERE AT IN THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ENABLE A
LARGE SCALE ADOPTION OBSERVES.
AND THEN MY OTHER QUESTION
WHICH IS SHORTER. IS HAS THERE
BEEN A STUDY OF THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT ON. ON PRICE AND
THEREFORE IMPACT ON- ACCESS TO
VEHICLES FOR THE FOR WORKING
CLASS MIDDLE CLASS. FAMILIES
AND HOUSEHOLDS BECAUSE IF YOU
YOU KNOW JUST LAW OF SUPPLY AND
DEMAND ECONOMICS IF YOU
CAPRICORNUS IN PARTICULAR
THING. YOU TEND TO DRIVE THE
COST OF THAT THING UP. AND I'M
WONDERING WHETHER THERE'S BEEN
SOME SORT OF ANALYSIS OF THAT.
THAT'S WHAT THE FIRST QUESTION
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE YOU'RE
1100% CORRECT IF WE STARTED
THIS TODAY AND HAD A TENFOLD
INCREASE BY NEXT YEAR. IT WOULD
BE A DISASTER WHICH IS WHY I
THINK THAT. IF HOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS NOW WE'RE
SAYING BY TWENTY TWENTY THIRTY
FOUR. YOU WANT TO BE SIXTY
PERCENT. GREATER THAN WHAT WE
WERE. IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
YEARS AGO THE ROUGHLY 50%
IMPROVEMENT IN TEN YEARS. I
THINK TEN YEARS GIVES US ALL A
GOOD TIME TO INCREASE. OUR
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE NOW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS A SERIOUS
INVESTMENT FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
OF CHARGING STATIONS. I KNOW I
HAD THE BILL THERE'S MULTIPLE
OTHERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AFTER FOR THAT GOAL THEIR THERE
ARE ARE NOT ENOUGH. BUT IF
PEOPLE WE NEED IT CHARGING
STATIONS FOLLOW THE AMOUNT OF
VEHICLES THAT ARE OUT THERE.
AND RIGHT NOW THERE ARE ROUGHLY
EQUIVALENT NOT. PROBABLY ENOUGH
THAT WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
RAMP UP. AS FAR AS THE OVERALL
COST I THINK THAT'S JUST A RED
HERRING EUROPE POLICY IF YOU
LOOK. AT HOW THIS BILL WOULD
WORK. THERE ARE SOME AUTO
MANUFACTURERS UNLIKE AND NAME
THEM HE BY NO THERE'S IT HALF A
DOZEN- SO IT. THAT ARE ON THEIR-
GUARANTEED TO NOT HAVE TO MEET
THIS THRESHOLD AND THEY'RE
GOING TO BE SELLING CARS AT THE
LOWER END. OF THE COST RAPTURE
THAT ARE AT PAR WITH INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE SEDAN. AS
WELL LETTER STATES. AND IT'S
THE SAME PRICE BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU DON'T TO PAY FOR GAS.
RIGHT SO IT'S EVEN LOWER SO TO
SAY THAT'S GONNA WAS GONNA BE.
MORE EXPENSIVE. FOR WORKING
CLASS CALIFORNIANS I THINK THE
OFFICE LOOK AT ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT LIVE. IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND HAVE TO COMMUTE TO
THE BAY AREA. YOU KNOW THERE
THERE'S A HUGE COST FOR THEM.
AND RIGHT NOW THAT DID THAT I
DON'T KNOW THE WHITE INDIVIDUAL
MORE PEOPLE ARE DOING IN THE
FIRST PLACE. LARGE PART TWO IS
IT'S- THE REBATES AREN'T ALWAYS
AVAILABLE AND IS ON A CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT AS WE MOVE
ALONG. THAT'S GOING TO
COMMUNITY INCREASE AND IT'S
GOING TO BE EVEN CHEAPER AND
IT'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
GREATER IMPACT ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT. DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION FOR MR BERMAN. THANK
YOU- ADAM CHANNEL I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO AND
I'M CALLING FROM RIVERSIDE- FOR
A JOINT OFFERING THIS IS REALLY
GOOD BILL AND ONE OF- FOLLOW UP
ON A COUPLE OF POINTS IN
QUESTIONS OF AND REYES THE
FIRST TO MAKE CLEAR THAT. IT IT
WILL BE THE OB- THE
MANUFACTURER IS THE ONE THAT
WOULD PAY A FEE- SO THE SO THE
FEET OR THEY SHOULD BE THE
PENALTY- IF THEY DON'T COMPLY
WITH THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
IS THE MANUFACTURER WHO WOULD
PAY THAT PENALTY BUT BUT LIKE-
THE AUTHOR SAID. HOPEFULLY A
LOT OF MANUFACTURERS NEVER PAY
THIS PENALTY- AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE EFFORTS OF ALL
THE MAKERS AND THAT'S REALLY
FRAME THE WAY THAT WE VIEW THIS
BILL SEVERAL OF THE LARGEST
AUTOMAKERS AND THE OTHERS SPOKE
TO A COUPLE THEM AS ONE PLUS IS
OUT A LITTLE BIT. I PLEDGE TO
CHANGE THE WAY THEY DO BUSINESS
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWO
YEARS AGO VOLVO ANNOUNCED THAT
IT PLANNED TO MAKE ALL OF YOUR
CARS 50% OF GLOBAL SALES BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. EARLIER
THIS YEAR THEY DOUBLE DOWN AND
SAID THAT THEY WILL MAKE ONLY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES BY TWENTY
THIRD BEFORE THE. THE THIS BILL
WOULD WOULD YEAH. WE DON'T GET
THIRTY. LOWER THAN BASELINE
3040% BY TWENTY THIRTY. THEY'RE
SAYING THEY CAN BE A HUNDRED
PERCENT. IN JANUARY GENERAL
MOTORS PLEDGED TO STOP MAKING
GASOLINE POWERED. PASSENGER
CARS VANS AND SUVS. BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. THEN FORD
ANNOUNCED THAT IT WOULD INVEST
TWENTY NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. EARLIER
THIS YEAR VOLKSWAGEN ANNOUNCED
THAT BY TWENTY THIRTY. IT'S
EXPECTED THAT 50% OF ITS
VEHICLE SALES IN THE U. S. WILL
BE FOR ELECTRIC. ALONG WITH 70%
OF SALES. IN EUROPE SO MANY
FACTORS ARE ALREADY MOVING DOWN
THIS PATH. AND SO YEAH THOSE
MANUFACTURERS. ASSUMING THEY
MEET THE GOALS THAT THEY HAVE
PUBLICLY STATED. WON'T PAY. ANY
PENALTY AT ALL. ACTIONS LIKE
THESE ARE PROOF THAT THE BILL'S
GOAL OF ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
FUTURE. ISN'T JUS ASPIRATIONAL
BUT IT IS REALISTIC AND
ACHIEVABLE. IN THE BILL SHOULD
BE VIEWED IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
ACTIONS ANNOUNCED. BY AUTO
MAKERS ALREADY. JUST MAKE BUT
JUST MAKING MORE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES IT WON'T SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF CONCISELY SUMMED UP THE
CHALLENGE IN THE BILL ANALYSIS.
NOTING THAT AND I QUOTE.
EXPONENTIAL GROWTH WILL REQUIRE
A STRATEGY TO ENCOURAGE VEHICLE
SALES. THROUGH STANDARDS
IMPOSED ON AUTO MANUFACTURERS
INCENTIVES. TO ENTICE
CONSUMERS. AND TO INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF CHARGING AND
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE I AGREE.
WITH THE CONCERN AROUND THAT
BUT- YEAH WE CAN'T SAY WE
EXPECT. YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH SOMETHING LIKE
TWENTY THIRTY FOUR WHY IS IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. ALREADY
EXIST IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE
HAVE A BIG BIG- ROBUST PLANS TO
MEET THE EEVEE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE BOTH STATE
FUNDED A FEDERALLY FUNDED.
PRIVATE ECTOR FUNDED- TO MEET
THESE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
GOALS THAT WE'VE SET. SO THIS
BILL IS NOT ONLY ALONG WITH THE
AUTOMAKER'S PLEDGES. BUT IT
TAKES THE NECESSARY NEXT STEPS.
TO INCENTIVIZE THE SALE OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES- SO I-
HUMBLY. ASKING HOPE MY
COLLEAGUES WILL JOIN ME IN
VOTING YES. ON AB TWELVE EIGHTY.
THANK YOU A VICE CHAIR UPON. I
THANK YOU THAT MY QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR I GUESS IS THAT I
FEEL LIKE THERE'S COMPETING OR
CONFLICTING GOALS IN THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION- ON THE ONE HAND
WE HAVE WE'RE HEARING FROM THE
MANUFACTURERS THAT SAY THAT
THEY WANT TO PRODUCE MORE THAT.
WHICH IS A POSITIVE THING AND
THEN ON THE OTHER HAND YOU'RE
IMPOSING A PENALTY ON ON A
CURRENTLY LEGAL PRODUCT- THE
GAS- POWERED VEHICLES AND THEN
ON THE OTHER HAND HE SAY WELL
WE HOPE THAT PENALTIES WOULD
NEVER BE IMPOSED BUT THEN ON
THE OTHER HAND EASE WE NEED
YOUR RAISING REVENUE FOR SAT
PROGRAMS TO SUBSIDIZE THE
PURCHASE. OF THAT SO IF YOU
NEVER IMPOSE THE PENALTIES YOU
WOULD YOU WOULDN'T GENERATE THE
REVENUE TO SUBSIDIZE THE
PURCHASE OF VEHICLES AND THE
MAIN FACTORS ALREADY DOING WHAT
YOU WANT TO DO. SO I GUESS
MAYBE CAN YOU CLARIFY KIND OF
YEAH. HOW THIS ALL PIECES
TOGETHER. YEAH THAT'S NOT I'LL
JUST TRY TO MAKE IT REALLY
SIMPLE WE WANT THEM TO GO
FASTER. AND STICK TO THEIR
PROMISE THEY'RE SAYING THEY'RE
GONNA GET THERE IN TIME. WE'RE
SAYING OKAY WE WANT TO
MEMORIALIZE YOUR COMMITMENT.
AND HAVE YOU HAVE SOME
REASONABLE- MARKERS IN THE
NEXT. THREE FIVE AND ROUGHLY
TEN YEARS. THAT THAT LOCK IN
THOSE ARE THOSE RATES AND IF
YOU DON'T REACH THOSE GOALS.
GOING TO- RECOGNIZE THAT AND
USE. AND HAVE- YOU KNOW A
FINANCIAL TOOL TO BASICALLY. IT
HAPPENED HAVE IS THEY HAVE A-
AN OPPORTUNITY TO STAY LUCK
YOU'RE PRODUCING MORE AND MORE
GROWTH POLLUTING CARS AND NINE
A- CLEAN CLEAN CLEAN CARS IN
CALIFORNIA SOON AND WHEN THEY
USE THE MONEY FOR IT FROM THAT
ACTION AND FURTHER SUBSIDIZE
PEOPLE WHO ARE BUYING CLEAN
CARS IN CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
PLACE SO. WE THINK IT MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE AND ALLOW THE
OPPOSITION SAYS THAT WE'RE
DOING THAT JUST DON'T DO IT
JUST DON'T FORCE US TO DO IT AS
FAST IS ACTUALLY. AND WE'RE
WILLING TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
AS FAR AS THE SPEED IN THE
DIRECTION AS FAR AS WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE GOING TO GO IN THE NEXT
TEN YEARS BUT ESSENTIALLY THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS MISTER VICE
CHAIR. IS CALIFORNIA COULD
STAND BACK AND SAY OKAY WE'RE
JUST GOING TO WAIT HERE IN TEN
YEARS AND SEE IF YOU'RE GONNA
DO THIS OR WE COULD COME UP
WITH A WASTED TRIP TO REALLY
PUSH THE ENVELOPE AND MAKE SURE
IT ACTUALLY HAPPENS BECAUSE
IT'S NOT JUST. SOME FEEL GOOD
THING AN ALTRUISTIC THING ABOUT
CLEAN CARS AS MY COLLEAGUE FOR
FIRMS IT'S AN EMPIRE SAID THIS
IMACT PEOPLE'S LIVES YOU KNOW
THEY SAY THAT THAT YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW IT'S REGRESSIVE IN YOUR
AREA TO THAT POOR AIR SO IN
LOWER INCOME AREAS THAT'S A BIG
IMPACT NOT JUST CLIMATE CHANGE
FOR ALL OF US WILD FIRES IN THE
IMPACT OF. ALL OF THAT BUT HOW
IT IMPACTS OUR ABILITY. TO LIVE
OUR LIVES TO BE ABLE TO BREATHE
CLEANER. I AYE SIR PREFER THE
ANSWER I GET. IF I COULD. IF I
COULD I GUESS WHAT I GATHERED
FROM THAT IS THAT. YOU DON'T
BULLARD. YOU ARE THE AUTHOR AND
MAY BE THE YEAR COLLEAGUES TO A
CO AUTHOR YOU LEAVE AND YOU
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE MAIN
FACTORS ARE MOVING FAST ENOUGH.
IS THAT IS THAT MY
UNDERSTANDING. IS THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE TRYING TO. PUT SOME TYPE
OF PENALTY IF THEY DON'T MOVE
FAST YEAH WE WANNA LAAKIIN SON
SOME PRODUCTION- GUIDELINES AND
MARKERS- BUT ALSO NOT ALL AUTO
MANUFACTURERS ARE STEPPING UP
LIKE VOLVO AND GENERAL MOTORS
AND HAVING CLEAR AND CONCISE
GOALS OF WHERE THEY WANT TO GET
BY. TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. WELL I MEAN I IT'S
CERTAINLY HAS MENTIONED BEFORE
ME THE GOALS OF THE GOALS AND I
DO BELIEVE THAT LEGISLATORS
SHOULD HAVE A ROLE IN SHAPING
THEM- VERSES THAT EXECUTIVE
ORDER. ACT I JUST ACT I'LL ALSO
I'M I'M GRAPPLING WITH JUST THE
CONFLICTING- PERSPECTIVE WITHIN
THE BILL BUT I CERTAINLY- I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE- YOUR WORK
BUT- I PROBABLY PUT THE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY
THANK YOU. WAS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE WISHING
TO SPEAK. WELL I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST THANK THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR HAVING A VERY
ROBUST AND VERY. I THINK
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION. ABOUT
THIS BILL AND ABOUT HOW WE CAN
ACHIEVE. THE GOALS THAT WE ALL
SHARE OF CLEANER AIR AND MOVING
TO IS THAT FUTURE. AND I DO
THINK THAT- THE DISCUSSIONS
ALSO REVEALED- THE- THE
STRENGTH OF THE BILL. DID YOU
KNOW THAT THE DESIRE IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE A HAND. IN
THE WAY THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER ABOUT- THIS IS
ROLLED OUT. A RECOGNIZING THAT
WE HAVE LOFTY GOALS ARE SET BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM BUT- WE ALSO.
NEED TO FIGURE OUT THE
MECHANICS OF HOW TO DO THAT AND
THAT IT SHOULD BE UP TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO THAT- BUT
ALSO LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS BILLS- ABILITY. TO DO THAT
AND I DO THINK THAT THERE IS A
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN. THE IDEA
OF HAVING A FUNDING SOURCE FOR
INCENTIVES THAT AT LEAST AT
THIS POINT WE NEED. FOR A LOT
OF OUR CONSUMERS TO PURCHASE
APPS. AND THESE BILLS ALSO
STATED GOAL OF NOT ACTUALLY
HAVING TO HAVE FINES. I THINK
THAT THAT IS A- BIT OF A-
DILEMMA WITHIN THE BILL THAT
NEEDS TO BE RESOLVED- AND- YOU
KNOW IF THE IF THE GOAL REALLY
IS THE C. B. R. P. FUNDING I
THINK THAT THIS. WE DO NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF THIS BILL TO
REALLY MAKE THAT SOMETHING
THAT'S CLEAR AND THAT DOESN'T
DO ANY DAMAGE TO A- LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES TO PEOPLE'S ABILITY
TO BUY ZAPS- IF IT IS TO. SPEED
UP THE PROCESS. YOU KNOW MAYBE
THAT'S A DIFFERENT CONVERSATION
AS WELL AND I AGREE WITH THE
AUTHORS. THAT WE DO NEED TO
SPEED THAT PROCESS UP WE THE
PLANET CAN'T WAIT. EVEN TEN
YEARS IS TOO LONG. THIS IS THE
VEHICLE THAT'S IN FRONT OF US
THAT WE HAVE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
DISCUSS THESE REALLY IMPORTANT
TOPICS THAT'S WHY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE BILL DOES
PASS OUT. BUT I ALSO HOPE THAT
THE AUTHORS. CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS. WITH THE
COLORS THAT THAT PHONE IN TODAY
I APPRECIATE THEM PHONING IT I
THINK THEY HAVE IMPORTANT. VERY
IMPORTANT PERSPECTIVE. AND I
WILL I WOULD URGE THE AUTHORS
TO SIT DOWN WITH ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS. WITH CARVED WITH
THE AUTO MANUFACTURERS. WITH OF
ORGANIZED LABOR.OF WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY THIS. TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS AND TO BE OPEN
TO NEW IDEAS. AND I HOPE THAT
THE STAKEHOLDERS. LABOR AND
EVERYONE ELSE IS WILLING TO SIT
DOWN WITH THE AUTHORS. AND TO
HELP CRAFT A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT REALLY
ACHIEVES EVERYBODY'S GOALS
HERE. AND I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
ALLOW ME TO CONTINUE TO BE PART
OF THE CONVERSATION I WOULD
LOVE TO. TO BE HELPFUL TO YOU
AS WELL. SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY ALTHOUGH I
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL. DOES
HAVE ALL A LOT OF WORK TO DO IN
THE OFFICE HAVEA LOT OF WORK
TO DO. I DID WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A
SECOND. MOTION AND A SECOND-
WITH THAT CAN WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL FOR THIS. THE MOTION TO
PASS TO THE- I'M SORRY I DID
NOT GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO CLOSE
AND- I WOULD INVITE YOU MISTER
MCCARTY TO CLOSE. THANK YOU I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORDS AND SAY YES I WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE YOU AND YOUR TEAM WORK
ON THIS AND- JUST. I THINK IT
OUGHT LOTS BEEN SAID I THOUGHT
TAKE MY CLOTHES FROM SO MY
JOINT AUTHORS. BUT IS ONE ISSUE
I WANTED TO ADDRESS WHEN THE A
LOT WE DIDN'T TALK A LOT ABOUT.
THE OPPOSITION. FROM THE
BUILDING TRADES. I WISH WE
COULD TALK ABOUT ONE ISSUE. OF
THE OF THE PRICE OF THESE CARS
WITH ANOTHER ON THEIR
UNAFFORDABLE FOR TOO MANY
LOWER. INCOME CALIFORNIANS AND
I. THINK THAT'S A FALLACY WE
TALK ABOUT THAT. BUT THEY'RE
BIGGER ISSUE WHICH I TOTALLY
CONCUR AND WE NEED TO RECONCILE
THAT. IS GONNA TALK ABOUT THEIR
LETTER IS THE REVENUE STREAM.
REVENUE STREAM TO FIX OUR ROADS
YOU LOOK ON THE FREEWAYS AROUND
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. TO MASSIVE
FIVE YEAR PROJECTS. TO FIX OUR
OUR ROADS ARE FREEWAYS AROUND-
THE CAPITAL CITY. AND IF WE DO
HAVE A DECLINING. A REVENUE
SOURCE WITH GAIL GAS GAS SALES
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT WILL HAVE A
DRAMATIC IMPACT WILL WE ADAPTED
SB ONE A COUPLE YEARS AGO. WE
DID INCREASE THE FEE WOULD CALL
THE TEST AS THE FIRST DAY. OF
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLES. AND SO I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO ADDRESS AND IF THIS IS
HAPPENING ANYWAY LOOK IT SAYS.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS ISSUE. BUT
THEY SHOULD SOMEONE TALK TO THE
OTHER MANUFACTURERS THEY'RE
DOING THIS ANYWAY. WE'RE JUST
SPEEDING IT UP. AND SO AS WE GO
DOWN THIS ROAD. NO PUN INTENDED
WE WILL HAVE TO CHANGE THE
FUNDING FOR OUR ROADS.
CONSTRUCTION ARE FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR FUN FOR THESE
GREAT CONSTRUCTION JOBS BUT
ALSO REALLY. ARE SO IMPORTANT
TO. OUR CALIFORNIA ECONOMY TO
MAKE SURE IT'S NOT BASED UPON.
A GAS SALES THAT BASED UPON-
THE FEE ON THE ON THE
AUTOMOBILES IF THEIR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE OR INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE SO. I THINK
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS. OTHERWISE EVERYTHING
YOU SAID IN YOUR COMMENTS I
CONCUR WITH. AS FAR AS
CONTINUING TO IT TO FLUSH OUT
THESE ISSUES AND WE HAVE. HAD
FRUITFUL CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
INDUSTRY BE CAN. TO DO SO. AND
I ASK HERE I THANK YOU. OKAY
WITHOUT ROLL CALL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO PROVIDE FRIEDMAN
HI FRIEDMAN HI FONG. SORRY
SEVEN NO ONE AND NO BERMAN.
BERMAN HI CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
NO DALY DALY NO DAVIES DAVIES
NO GIPSON KALRA. THREE HI
PLEASE I MEDINA. MEDINA I
NAZARIAN THIS AREA AND I WENT.
O'DONNELL WARD FOUR I WICKS
WICKS I WILL IS. SEVEN FOR OKAY
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
PERHAPS A MEMBERS I'M GOING TO
PASS THE GAVEL. TO MY VICE
CHAIR OF THE PERCENT. WE WILL
NOW HEAR FIVE NINE AB FORTY
THREE NINE THREE MAYES BEGIN
WHATEVER YOU READY THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THIS BILLIS BEEN THREE YEARS
NOW IN THE MAKING OF THIS IS A
BILL THAT PRIMARILY LOOKS AT
WAYS OF REDUCING OF GIVING
CITIES THE FLEXIBILITY OF BEING
ABLE TO CAPS SPEED LIMITS. TO
REDUCE TRAFFIC FATALITIES IN
TRAFFIC INJURIES. THANK YOU WE
ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED THIS BILL
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO- AND
CHAIRED THE DENTURE FRAZIER.
INSTEAD ASSETS TO CONVENE A
TASK FORCE WHICH IN HINDSIGHT
WAS ACTUALLY A REALLY REALLY
SMART THING TO DO BECAUSE WE
PUT TOGETHER A TASK FORCE OF
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ALL ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAD
TRIPLE A WE HAD LAW ENFORCEMENT
WE HAD THE SAFE STREETS
ADVOCATES HE REALLY BROUGHT
EVERYONE TOGETHER FROM URBAN
AREAS FROM RURAL AREAS. AND
FOUND. THAT SPEED IS A PROBLEM
THAT'S KILLING PEOPLE ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THAT CITIES AND MUNICIPALITIES
HAVE BEEN FOR YEARS ASKING FOR
SOME FLEXIBILITY FROM THE VERY
RIGID RULES THAT SET SPEED
LIMITS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BASICALLY THAT IN
ORDER TO ENFORCE SPEED LIMITS
CITIES HAVE TO DO A TRAFFIC
SURVEY VERY TEN YEARS. THEN
THEY HAVE TO SET THEIR SPEED
LIMITS AT THE EIGHTY THE EIGHTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE OF HOW FAST
PEOPLE ARE DRIVING REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THEY'RE SPEEDING.
THIS FORCES CITIES TO
CONSTANTLY RAISE SPEED LIMITS
REDUCED RESULTING IN A KIND OF
SPEED CREEP REGARDLESS OF THE
WISHES OF THEIR RESIDENTS TO
CONTROL SPEEDING ON OFTEN
RESIDENTIAL STREETS. LAST YEAR
DURING CODED WE HAD A- 13% DROP
IN THE MILES THAT WERE DRIVEN
IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE PEOPLE
WERE STAYING HOME. WHAT
HAPPENED IN TERMS OF FATALITIES
HOWEVER AND INJURIES WITH A 24%
INCREASE IN THE PER MILE
DEFINITELY. WHICH IS THE
HIGHEST EVER JUMP IN NINETY SIX
YEARS. BECAUSE WITH LESS CARS
ON THE ROAD PEOPLE DROVE FASTER
AND EVERY MILE AN HOUR FASTER
PEOPLE GO THE RATE OF INJURY
AND DEATH GOES UP ALMOST
EXPONENTIALLY. THIS IS ONE
PIECE OF THE TRAFFIC SAFETY
PUZZLE BUT A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE. WITH THAT I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE TODAY ON A. B. FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I DO HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE SALUTE SO LEADER
RENTALS FROM LA DOT AND BRIAN
TAYLOR. FROM UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO DISCUSS THE
HISTORY OF THE EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE AND ASK ANY ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS GREAT.
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE LINE
FOR SELENA. GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE SELENA RENTAL GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FORTY THREE LED O. T. SAFETY
IS OUR NORTH STAR OUR HIGHEST
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO IMPROVE
SAFETY FOR ALL ROAD USERS
WHETHER THEY DRIVE WALK BIKE OR
SCOOT NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ARE KILLED IN
CRASHES EACH YEAR MORE THAN
THREE TIMES THAT AMOUNT OR
SEVERELY INJURED SPEED IS THE
NUMBER ONE DETERMINING FACTOR
IN THE SEVERITY OF THE CRASH
JUST FIVE MILES AN HOUR CAN
MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
LIFE AND DEATH. PUT BLUNTLY
SPEED KILLS LA DOTD WILL
CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE
INVESTMENTS STATE STREET DESIGN
BUT ELIMINATING TRAFFIC
FATALITIES REQUIRES A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH STRICT
ADHERENCE TO THE EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE THE STATUS QUO IS A
FAILED STRATEGY THAT DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR VEHICLE PERFORMANCE
RELIES ON STRANGE ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES AND RESULT IN
INCREASING SPEED LIMITS WITH NO
END IN SIGHT. AB FORTY THREE
OPPORTUNITIES AN IMPORTANT TOOL
TO PROTECT ALL ROAD USERS BY
LETTING US ESTABLISH SIXTY ONE
IS OUR STREETS CURRENT LAW
COURSES CITIES TO SET THE
LIMITS THAT MATCH DRIVER
BEHAVIOR INSTEAD OF BRINGING
THAT BEHAVIOR IN LINE WITH
SIXTY GOALS BROKE WITH
CONDITIONS AND A LOT IT FORCES
US TO CHOOSE BETWEEN A STREET
THAT IS TOO FAST AND A STREET
THAT IS UNENFORCEABLE THAT'S
WHAT FORCES CITIES TO INCREASE
SPEED LIMITS DESPITE THE TRAGIC
PATTERN OF SEVERE INJURIES AND
DEATHS ARE TOO MANY OF OUR
STREET. BECAUSE OF THIS LAW WE
HAVE REDUCED THE SPEED LIMIT ON
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED MILES OF LA
STREET OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS
REGARDLESS OF CHANGING STREET
DESIGN EIGHTY FORTY THREE WILL
GET THE RESPECTABILITY IS THAT
IMPORTS WILL BE ONE OF THE
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS ARE DEADLY STREETS
AROUND SCHOOLS AND SENIOR
CENTERS IN AREAS OF HIGH
BUSINESS ACTIVITY WHERE MORE
PEOPLE ARE WALKING. EIGHTY
FORTY THREE WILL SAVE LIVES AND
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE YES MY
CHIEF ENGINEER DAN MITCHELL AND
I WILL REMAIN ON THE LINE. TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WELL NOW THAT A BRA
TAYLOR- YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD
ACTORS MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BRIGHT
TAYLOR FOR OF PLANNING PUBLIC
POLICY AND OF THE INSTITUTE
CASH COULD STUDIES THE UC.
SETTING UP SPEED ON ROADWAYS
REQUIRED BALANCING THE ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL BENEFITS OF VEHICLE
MOVEMENT ON ONE HAND. AGAINST
THE GREATER SAFETY
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HUMAN
ACTIVITY COSTA BASSMAN TRAFFIC
ON THE OTHER. DRIVERS AND
COMMERCIAL SHIPPERS TYPICALLY
FAVOR FASTER LIMITS THOSE
LIVING WALKING BIKING OR
PLAYING IN PROXIMITY TO ROSE UP
AND WENT SLOWER ONES. HOWEVER
THE MOST COMMON METHOD FOR
SETTING SPEED LIMITS LEAD TO
DRIVERS TO COLLECTIVELY DECIDE
HOW FAST IS TOO FAST. THE LONG
ESTABLISHED. TRAFFIC ON THE
ROADWAY AFTER THE POSTED SPEED
LIMIT AND THEN SETTING THE
LIMIT AT A FIVE MILE AN HOUR
INCREMENTS CLOSE TO THE SPEED
OF WHICH 85% OF THE VEHICLES
TRAVEL. THE WORLD WAS BORN IN
THE NINETEEN THIRTIES AND
FORTIES IN THE LOGIC THAT MOST
DRIVERS OPERATED SAY SPEEDS
MOST OF THE TIME. AND IT SEEMS
THAT ABOUT 15% OF THE DRIVERS
DRIVE FOR FASTER THAN THEY
SHOULD. RESEARCHERS IN THE UCLA
STUDENT TRANSPORTATION SPENDING
THEM HISTORICAL ORIGINS OF THE
EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE AND
FOUNDED EARLY ARCHITECTS
CONSIDERED A REASONABLE. POINT
FOR SETTING SPEED LIMITS
PRIMARILY IN RURAL AREAS
SUBJECT TO FOLLOW UP SAFETY
EVALUATIONS IMPOSSIBLE. JUST
BUT OTHER TIME THIS. STAR POINT
OF A INTO A HARD. WILL PERCENT.
WHICH IS NOW BUT IT'S A- INTEND.
THE EIGHTY FIFTY. RULED A TIME
WHEN THE MAIN GOAL OF ST. AND
WHICH AND BOAT TRAFFIC FLOWS
INTO. BUT THE MOTOR. USE OFF
THE STREET. AND ON THIS. IN THE
BUILDING. TODAY HOW MANY URBAN
INTERESTED PLAN. INCREASINGLY
ARE FOR. NON D. TRAVEL. BACK ON
TO MAKE THEM WORK. LEFT ON BY.
DRIVING AND I. STATE. IN
ADDITION TO DRY OUT IS NEEDED
DRY COURSE. OF SPEEDS MAYBE
INCREASE AT ALL WITH THE OF
OTHERS USED. SINCE MODERN
VEHICLES EQUIPPED BETTER PER
DRY MOVE AT HIGHER. WELL IT TO
THAT THE- CYCLING AND OTHERS
YOU DO WITHIN THE- INDEED TO
SEE THE SEVENTEEN THE NEXT
TRAFFIC. BOARD THIS CALL FOR
ALTERNATIVE OKAY WHAT ARE MY
ABOUT THOSE ARE TAILORED.
VULNERABLE USERS. YET. OKAY
SORRY A LOT YOUR YOUR TIME IS
RUNNING OUT TO DO MY WRAPPING
UP. YES WITH BY A COUPLE
TRANSIT ALL CUT TO COMPETE
SPEECH EIGHT FIFTH PERCENTILE
WILL. JUST GIVE THE BEST INCOME.
CALIFORNIA VISIONS. AFTER ALL
IT'S THE CREATORS OF ROLE SO I
IS THE STAR POINT AND NOT ALLOW
WORD ON TRAFFIC. THANK YOU. BUT
MR TAYLOR- SEEING I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANYONE ENOUGH-
SO WE WILL NOW- SEEING NO. THE
END OF IN THE CHAMBER AND TO
SPEAK ON EITHER ON THE BILL I
DURING IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
LOOKING. SCENE NINE- THE
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE THAT WE LIKE TO. SPEAK
AND OF AB FORTY THREE ON THE
PHONE. THANK YOU THEY AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN. AT THIS TIME
AGAIN ONE ZERO YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. AND FIRST FIRST I IN
AND LINE NOW NINETY TWO IT'S
GOING. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
ROUGHED UP ON BEHALF THE CITY
OF IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE OF THE LEAD SHOT
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES STRONG WORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON OF AN AFRICAN ABOUT
LOCATION I THINK IT'S ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF DENVER AND OTHER
HOW. PAGE NOT BERMAN BUT FOR AN
EIGHTY FORTY THREE. THANK YOU
NOW. TO TWENTY ONE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN JOSH SHAW FOR THE
SENATE MUNICIPAL AGENCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NOW TO LINE NINETY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON CARTER
RIBBON FROM NRDC IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND.
SIXTEEN ONE SIXTEEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS DURING THE DEERS AND
I'M CALLING WITH WALK HIM AND
JUST GO IN AND PULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AN OUTLINE TWENTY
TWO. HI DAVID HAD TO DEAL WITH
A RP CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE. HI LEAH
SHEA WHIGHAM WITH THE VISION
ZERO NETWORK BASED IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN ONE
EIGHTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON STEVEN
TO FROM SELF ABOUT LEADERS
GROUP WHERE PRODUCT THIS BILL
THREE TRAFFIC THANK YOU FOR
LEADERSHIP SHARE. THANK YOU AND
OUT OF NINETY SIX. MISTER
CHAIRMAN DON'T EXPECT REP THE
METROPOL TRAINS COMMISSION
TRANSPORT. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU
OPERATOR- ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE QUEUE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY THREE.
OKAY AGAIN NOW PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. AND WE HAVE KNOWN
CLEAN UP. BUT THE GOVERNOR OF
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS TODAY. THANK YOU
MR VICE CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
SALUTE OUR CHAIR MISS FRIEDMAN
FOR HER OUTSTANDING WORK IN THE
SUBJECT AREA STEMMING BACK A
FEW YEARS AGO WORK WHERE THE
TASK FORCE WAS SET UP. AND NOW
HER IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TASK
FORCE RECOMMENDATIONS IS JUST
AN OUTSTANDING PIECE OF WORK
AND I'M- PROUD TO SUPPORT. I
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER WORK.
THANK YOU AND I ALSO WANT TO
ECHO AND I REALLY THINK THE
CHAIR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I COMING FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LAST YEAR AND SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS WE HAVE AND ALSO A
VERY ORGANIZED ENVIRONMENT WHEN
PEOPLE LEARN ABOUT THE EIGHTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE RULED THAT
SOMETIMES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE NO CHOICE BECAUSE THE CODE
IS WHAT IT IS AND YOU JUST HAVE
TO FOLLOW THAT. AND WE SEE-
BUSINESS DISTRICT THAT MIGHT
HAVE A FORTY MILE PER HOUR ZONE
NOT RUNNING RIGHT THROUGH THEM
AND- YOU DON'T LOCAL
NEIGHBORHOODS WHO KNOW THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD THE BEST WANTING
TO SEE A LITTLE BIT OF TRAFFIC
CALMING GOING ON YES WE NEED
MORE INVESTMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
IN A BIG WAY- BUT WE ALSO HAVE
I THINK THROUGH. RAPIDLY
EVOLVING TECHNOLOGIES IN THE
DIRECT COMMUNICATIONS TO CARS
THAT SHOW YOU WHAT THE SPEED
LIMITS ARE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT MADE BETTER INFORMED
ABOUT HOW TO PRIVACY FOR SPEED
FOR THE EXISTING ENVIRONMENT IN
THE SURROUNDING NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEED KILLS- IT'S BOTH THE MASS
ACCELERATION SO IT'S NOT JUST
THE SPEED BUT WE KNOW ALSO CARS
HAVE GOTTEN HEAVIER VIEW. ARE
GONNA LITTLE BIT MORE OVER TIME
HERE SO IT'S A BIT THAT WE CAN
DO TO GET LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AFFLECK'S. TO- BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE PARAMETERS THAT ARE COMING
FOR A SAFER ENVIRONMENT HAPPY
TO ADD ON IS A COLLAGE AS WELL
THIS IS REALLY GOING TO BENEFIT
THE DISTRICT LIKE MINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ON THE RESUME.
WORKS THANK YOU ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOUNG FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FOR YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT
IS SEEN- VERY TRAGIC AND
PREVENT. DEATHS OF SPEEDING-
AND PEOPLE WHO SERIOUSLY
IMPACTED THE REST OF LIVES AND
THE IS SOMETHING THAT
PREVENTABLE I HAVE A STRONG
CYCLE- COMMUNITY- IN MY
DISTRICT PEOPLE WHO BOTH ARE
CYCLISTS FOR FUN AND EXERCISE
BUT ALSO WHO COMMUTE TO WORK-
BY CYCLING WE NEED TO DO MORE
FOR THEM. I THINK THIS IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THIS ON
AND I'D LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR AS WELL. THANK YOU
CAPITA YOU BOTH THANK YOU AT. A
CELEB IS AREA- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR EIGHT ADD ON AS A ME TOO
NEED TO- AS FOR THIS BILL VERY
MUCH I WANT TO JUST SAY THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOUR
PERSEVERANCE AND WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE I'VE SUPPORTED SOME
OF YOUR PREVIOUS SIMILAR
MEASURES AND THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL- AND I WANTED TO JUST
POINT OUT THAT NINE YEARS AGO
WHEN I FIRST CAME UP HERE- MY
FIRST BILL THAT I INTRODUCED
WAS. A. EXTENDING THE YELLOW
LIGHT- BY THE SEC. SO THAT
WOULD HAVE. IMPROVE A LOT OF
ACCESS THAT AND FOR. WE HAVE.
IN ESPECIALLY SOME OF THE-
DENSER URBAN SETTING SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS.
BEFORE TO SUPPORTING IT AND IF
IT HASN'T BEEN SECOND AND-
MOVED YET I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND-
WELL OFFERED TO THE CHAIR TO
CLOSE WELL I WANT TO THANK THE
SUPPORT OF MANY OF YOU IN THE
COMMITTEE- THE BILL IS A-
NARROW IT'S NOT IT GETTING RID
OF THE EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE
BUT IT DOES. GIVE CITIES MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF BEING
AROUND VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
AROUND SCHOOLS AND AROUND
SENIOR CENTERS- AND IN HIGH
INJURY NETWORKS SO WE THINK
IT'S A VERY BALANCED APPROACH
pSAFETY PUZZLE AND WITH THAT ON.
OUR BEHALF OF OUR SENIORS AND
OUR CHILDREN PARTICULARLY I
WOULD REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU VENTURE A
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN IPHONE FIVE PHONE I
BERMAN. BERMAN I CUTTING.
CUNNINGHAM I DALY. DALY HI
DAVID. THE I GIVE. KALRA KALRA
I READ HELP KIDS IN. EARLY LI I
MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN THIS
AREA I WENT. WHEN I O'DONNELL.
PHOTON IS THAT I. OKAY L.
DONALD I. WARD FIVE WHICH WICKS
I. FOR VOTERS FIFTY ZERO VOTE
FIFTEEN OKAY THE ROLE OPEN FOR
MEMBERS. THANK YOU AND WITH
THAT WE'RE GONNA LOW THE CALL
THE- PREVIOUS BILLS. SIX FOR. I
AND THE FINAL VOTE IS FIFTEEN
ZERO FOUR ITEMS ON CONSENT.
HERE RIGHT WITH ONE IS. THIRTY
ALL RIGHT FILE ITEMS AB TWELVE
EIGHT CURRENT VOTES FOUR GIPSON.
NOT VOTING K. KALRA- LET'S HERE
FILE ITEM FOR AB TWELVE EIGHTY
MCCARTY HI KALRA WENT. NOT
O'DONNELL. THE HURDLE YEP I'M
NOT OKAY HELLO NOT VERY OKAY
FINE VOTE IS. EIGHT FOUR. SHE
FOLLOWED SEVEN AB A NINE VOTE
TEN ONE. DAVIES I'M SORRY-
THERE EIGHTY NINE- SEE HERE
GIPSON. RIGHT YEAH- GIVE I MISS
AREA HI NAZARIAN I'VE WENT.
NONVOTING O'DONNELL WHICH I'M
NOT- FILE THE SEVEN THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE MCCARTY YES A RACE.
HELLO REYES EVISCERATES OFF NAY.
DO YOU KNOW DONALD. OKAY FILE
ITEM FIVE AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN.
YOU CAN SO WHEN IS MOVING FROM
NOT VOTING TO OPPOSE SO IT'S
EIGHT FINALISTS EIGHT FIVE.
COURSE. YOU'VE GOT A- EVERYBODY
ON THE FORTY THREE GET
EVERYBODY OKAY. OKAY PLEASE
TAKE DO WE HAVE ALL OF MEMBER
FOR KNOWING ALL OF THEBILLS
THAT THEY WANT TO VOTE ON WE
HAVE ALL THE NUMBERS REPORTED
ON ALL THE BILL THEY WANT TO GO
TO. RESTORED TO YOUR GOOD. OKAY
WITH THAT WE ARE TURNED.